carol baskin suing
netflix over tiger king too
carol's about that
carol's that you know
she's such that she's like such a tough
she's like the
karen it feels like of the tiger kingdom
and i think we might have gotten a video
from carol
uh
when we did that christmas spectacular
show last year
we might have got a video sent in from
her i'm not sure if so i'll see if a
cameo
see if we can put in this episode but um
hey all you cool cats and kittens it's
carol baskin from big cat rescue
theo and tammy i'm so happy to see you
together here in the new year
i hope you and all of your fans have a
perfect 2021
and remember the big cats always get the
best beef
tiger king 2 she argues that producers
are simply rehashing repackaging unused
stuff to make it seem like she has given
new interviews or insight
that's every
sequel that's all that is all the
documentaries the second one now is just
uh
they interview one like outside
character
they'll interview probably a real tiger
they'll probably interview tony the
tiger
he's like i don't know you know i was
eating kellogg's i don't know i don't
know
you know i don't i'm shocked what they
were doing to these other tigers
i'm just a drawing so
if i'm hungry they draw me a steak they
draw me a uh
bird
so
that's it they're saying they're going
you know she's going to sue them good
for carol sit look
silly
sue that's where it says people suing
each other every day people suing not
shocked
sue netflix
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one